my name is donyen lin i was born
in beijing china and i moved to canada
when i was 16.
my research is on the intersection of
neuroscience and ai
and i study how basically these two
fields can complement and advance each
other
[Music]
i would say the digital brain because
basically that is where
our research is going right now
[Music]
there are so many of them and you know
each of them sort of um influenced me uh
in a different way
um but if i have to pick one i think i'd
have to say dr sarah sola
who is a professor in
physiology at northwestern university
and you know last year i had this
amazing experience organizing this
conference
and we invited sarah as a speaker
and you know she talked about basically
her journey of moving to the states um
from the argentina
and then
you know sort of being one of the few
women in her field
and just you know the struggles and then
the journey of finding herself etc and
honestly that was just one of the most
enlightening conversations i've had in
my grad school journey
absolutely
so this summer i had the opportunity to
get involved in a project called ai for
good
which is a lab which is summer lab that
is founded by one of the mila professors
doing a pre-cup and basically the goal
is to sort of address the gender
imbalance in the field of ai by
providing training opportunities for
undergraduate women across canada and
then there i met a lot of amazing girls
who are
aspiring to become an ai scientist and
you know it's really
good to be part of the journey of you
know helping them develop this career
and you know helping them just make the
first step towards towards that career
aspiration
[Music]
it's absolutely amazing um i think the
important thing is that montreal as a
city it's really young it's really fun
and then it's really people oriented and
and you know by that i mean um it's
really a city built for people to live
in you know you walk out of your door
and then right next to your apartment
there's a park you can just walk there
and sit on a bench and then you can
watch sunset and then on your way home
you can grab a bagel it's absolutely
stunning to live here
i mean i've received a lot of tips on
how to do research etc
but i would say
that the most influential one to me is
to be patient and just trust the process
put in the work
and you know there are a lot of people
out there who are just trying to publish
20 papers a year
the whole purpose of being here and
doing this phd thing
is just so that you can get really deep
into a topic and at the same time you
can expand your interest and you can
explore what you like and i feel like
that's the goal instead of you know just
counting how many papers you publish